on the outside of winterfell the night
king and his army of the undead are
getting ready to assault the kingdom
daenerys and john are on high alert
ready to go at any moment with their
dragons arya has her tricks but she's
not used to fighting with bows or swords
sansa is trying to get back into
fighting form with tyrion by her side
but they are still worried about bran
even though he's gone a thousand feet
into a well
inside winterfell ari and sansa are in a
tower when they hear a noise in the
courtyard they both go downstairs and
find bran climbing out of the well he
tells them that he's been in there for
days and the night king has been trying
to talk to him but he just ignored him
and crawled out
daenerys and jon lead their army into
battle to fight the night king the night
king is a formidable foe and has a red
dragon dany and jon send their dragons
to attack him while everyone else fights
on the ground arya defends herself by
throwing around glass bottles with
poison in them to kill white walkers and
bran wargs into a fighter's mind to help
him fight against his opponents
the night king makes a move as he shoots
an ice spirit daenerys targaryen who has
been coming towards him but before it
hits her jon slices it in half letting
it hit two different people on both
sides of her then he runs towards her
and takes cover behind her as they dodge
fireball shot from three separate
directions that manage to hit them both
daenerys is about to run out of ammo for
her dragon ball but jon pitches to bran
stark who throws a fireball into the air
which scorches through an overhead beam
sending burning wood everywhere which
sets the trench on fire meanwhile in
winterfell arya witnesses her family
members all getting killed by white
walkers or their zombie army of whites
this leads her into a catatonic state
until she hears tyrion's voice calling
out for help on top of one of the towers
arya rushes to the top of the tower to
see tyrion being overwhelmed by zombies
she slices through zombies with her
sword the valyrian steel blade needle
she helps tyrion down from the tower
where they escape into the forest after
they stop to catch their breath tyrion
thanks arya for saving his life he says
i owe you one but ari cuts them off and
replies you don't owe me anything they
sit in silence for a while until tyrion
stares at arya's deep brown eyes and
says
are you scared of me no i'm not scared
of you
i'm not here to hurt you i need your
help
i don't want to help you please i'm
begging you
why should i help you because i need you
what if i don't want to help you then i
don't know what will happen
i'll help you turian breathes a sigh of
relief
back at winterfell the dragons are
running out of fuel their only hope is
that their dragons aren't completely out
of fuel yet if they can just hold off
the night king for a little while longer
they just might have enough time to land
and refuel them in time for them to save
winterfell
jon has faith in daenerys's dragon
because he saw it save his life when he
was fighting the night king daenerys on
the other hand is afraid for her dragon
because it reminds her when she was
younger when her father would fly her up
into the air to drown her in water just
for fun
eventually daenerys and john's dragons
are killed because of a white that
stabbed one of them in the eye with an
arrow the night king then resurrects his
other dragons and it looks like he's
going to win but then arya quickly jumps
onto a dragon and flies up over the
battlefield toward the night king's red
dragon which she knocks out of the sky
with an arrow shot from her bow still on
top of her own dragon
getting away from the night king she
finds herself in front of two ice giants
who also try to knock her out of
winterfell but arya finds she can't
control them like puppets which leads to
her death as one hits arya's body
fatally
jon snow knows they're screwed and he
looks around at his devastated team and
realizes that they can't go on without
arya he'll have to sacrifice the rest of
them to save her daenerys grabs him by
the shoulder but he shrugs her off i
need to trust my instincts he says
it's not about strategy anymore he takes
off running unsure of whether any of
them are even paying attention anymore
he reaches out for arya who was once
again totally visible to him and pulls
out her soul into his chest this time
permanently
jon snow has came back from the dead in
the past but now he's got supernatural
powers
he can see in any darkness and wield
swords that glow in the night
and just when life starts to reclaim
some of its bloom jon snow is confronted
with his most dangerous foe yet the
night king
jon snow has been fighting the white
walker since before he could walk but
now it's time to take him on
don stone knows this is going to be a
one-on-one fight for survival and he
summons all of his supernatural powers
to take him down
ultimately jon snow is victorious and
it's revealed that jon snow's powers are
actually from the force
you